WHERE ATNI
WOALT
NING AFT
ITH UNCASE OR BEIN
GOOD NEWFIRSTISAN PASSAGE OF
CHINA ON THE MANUFACRIF
SEMIUC
POSSIBLE
PLACKLE THE
S THAT
S.BREAKTOUFTER MORE THAN
OF ATIONS BETWEEN
DEMOCRATIC SATOR JOE
AND SENATE
HUVERYONE IN
WASE. INVEST   ENERGE
EXTEND AR
CLOS FOR-DODGING
RPT REPORTN IN PROFIT.
BUT WITH 1 DAYTH
MIDTERMS, WILL THESE SUCCESSES
ANN HILL SS BEFORE NOVEMBER?
BE ABLE TO GET THE BILL TO
PRN'S DESK?DE MANCHIN
OFRGINIA JOINS US NO
DISCUSS.
SENATOR, THANKS SOUCR
JOINING US
U SAID>> THANKS FOR HAVI
YOUD YONTED TO WAIT TO PASS ANJ
LEGISLATION BECAUSE OF THE
INFLATION RATE.N HASN'T GONE DO
DAYS.
>> JAKE,HA MIND, CHUCK -- WE
TO CHU CDIE
OU KEPT THROUGH.
WED
L. THERE
WERE THINGS IN THERE I COD BE
NSO BE INFN IS TS E GREATESTENGE
RY RIGHT NOW AND N MY STATE AND.
SO, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE .TARTED T.
WE GOT THE BILL DOWN TO WHERE
NOHAT. HEAR THATM , YOU'
WE'RE PAYING DOWN
BILLION.
WE'R PDUR AS IF YOU WANT TO GEE
GASOLINEDOWN, PRODUCE
MORE ENERGY AND PRODUC H
WEERYTHINGG BACK, KEEP PVESTINGN
IN
G
AND ONORMAL TIMES,AN COLLEAGUES
INSU
CUE BASICAN DEBT S
WHAT THEY WANT.
WEE D RMITTING,
WANT, IN
PRODUCTION OF ENERGY, WHICH IS
SIU ANNOUNCED YOP NUMBERE D DOI.
FE R
THERS A WHARTON T
LLOTE,WOUL SLI
ATION UNTIL  A
DECREASETER,
A W ATION  REPUBCALEASED
ANYSIS YESTERDAYT
IN THE SOU
WOULD ACTUALLY RESULT IN A SMALL
AMICSAIDT RMBUFOR
WHAT EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE THAT
THIS BILL LL
D  INCREAS
>>CKT OF, DISAGREE WITH THE
PE WHARTON.
THEY'VE WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
WE'VH TH
WET  DISAGREEMENON
THIS.
ITASN, OY?T GOING TOPERMANT.
WELL, WE FOUND OUT THE
E WR WORAN
INFLA
INFLAMMATO?N IT ADD FLAMES TO T
NOW RE DEBT?
DOING IT CLEANER ANYWHER T
WORLD.
DITS TTERIESOUR CARSO
AND THESE ARE SOLUON MS WE HA
EVERYONELE LAS NOT A DEAL.. IA
THIS IS N PEOPLE
ENERGY APPROACH. ND A BANC
>> KNOTHERE ARE THOSE LIKE
LARRY SUMMERS WHO DO NOT THINKI.
DO YAVENCE, ARE THERE
STUDY                          T
ATION TO
EDT EVERYTHING AD
EVERYONE CROSS-SECTIONING THISS
TAX RATE WAS 35%2017, .
14% REDUCTIOKE.
I'M SORRY.
TO O PROBLE
I KNOW YOUFRIEND% REDUCTION AND
THAT WASOUS, TWERE LED.
THAND WE -I EW THERE WERE PEOPL.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN WEST IA, Y
AT LEAST 21% OR MORE ANDD
THE COUNTRY.
T TH
THE TALKEDVE ANIMUM WHEN W
WE NEVER RAISED TAXES.
WE ARE SAYING CLOSE THY THE TAXE
TTED STATES TREASUR
E GOING TO CREATE MORE N AYERS .
T LOW
THE GAPUMP,
HOPEFULLY LOWER PRICESTORE AND
DAILY NEEDS.
ENERGY PRICECIALLYERGY IS A DRIH
BILL.
ANYTHING PUBLICLY ABOUT THIS
PLAN.
WE KNOW SHE HASEINE THAT, R INSE
AX RATEAD OF
ENE LASTE YOU SPOKE
WITH SENATOR SINEME U OPEN TT
SUGGEST?
>> OF ALL, SENATOR SINEMA
IS MY DEARRIEND.
WE WORKED VERY CLOSE TOGETHER O.
SHE HAS UCH IN THIS PIECE OFGIS.
E'IT OF IT Y HARD.T SHE'S BROUG
DR
SHRUMENTN AND
BRING DOWN THE PRICE OF  WIL APT
ERICA.
I AGREE WIER WE'RE NOT
GOING TO RAISE TAXES AND WE
DON'T.
AND ONHA INKICALLY
WHEN SHE LOOKS AE BILL AND
SEES THE SPECTT
WE'RE DOING AND AL
'RE IN
PRICED FIGH
INFLATION, BRINGING PRICES DOWN.
SHE'LL MAKE HER DECISI A SPECT .
>> WHEN DID YOU LAST WITH
HER?
AND ARE YOU CONFIDENT WILL
BE ON BOARD?
>>SPOU KNOW, I
SPEAK WITH EVERYBODY, AS YOUOW.
BEEN VERY FENDLY.
WE SPEAK A
YOU SEE USE FLOO
NG
ASON PEOPLE WE TT
THINK IT WOULD COME TO FRUITION.
PEOPLE AGAIN.SAPIN
DISAPPOINTED
EVERYONE WAS ALL UPSET Y DELEGA.
PY COULDN'T GEE WI
BACK BET $3.5 TRILLION O
SPENDING.TAKING5 TRILLION OF
SPENDING DOWN TO $40BILLIOT'S D
GOING TO MAKE A FF I
AMERICA ANS
POCKETBOOK.ATION.THAT'S WHAT WE.
SO, WITH DIDN'T WANTO
ANY ANTICIPATI UP EN THEY COME A
WNA YO
THIS.
SO, D  WITH MY STAFF.
THIS E
APRIANY DILIGENTLY, AN
A E CAMEK,
TO CHUCK L'STALKING SOMEWE DID L
THIS TO PUT IT IN PO W
HAVE TODAY WHICH IS A GREARTUNII
IS  BILL.IT'S RED, WHITE AND BL
>> SENAT AUGUST
RECESS AT THE END OFS WEEK.
THAT'S THE SCHEDULE ANYWAY.
WILL YOU HAVE PASSED THI
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU GO BACK
HOME TE HOPE SO.THINK THAT'S BE
I DIDN'T -- YOU KNOW, WHEN I
CAME -- I WAS -- WHEN IT CAME
WAS KIND OF CONFINED UP AND D II
EVERYTHING, BUT WE WERE WORKING
DAILY, DAY AND
ISNG, EVERYONE WAS
INTERACTING AND THINGS STAO
COME TOGETHER.
BY WEDNESDAY WE HAE ALL ED ON.
THE PRESIDENT AGREED ON IT. DID
AND CHUCK SCHUR D I AGRE IT.
T FOR
THING WE'VE WORKED ON FOR A
LONG TIMINK THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT. PASSES
POISED TO BEF THBIGGEST ACN
ID
WHAT ROLE DID PRESIDENT BIDEN
PLAY IN THESGODO FOR
OH, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU DON'T DONYHIS
SIZE, THIS MAGNITUDE CHANGIN THO
PRODTION WE HAVE IN OU
COUNTRY.ES THEES
PORTFOO E ENERGY OFUTURE.
IFES JOBS  HERE
BECAUSE WE GIVE INCENTIVWE DIDNC
ANYBODY.
WEE  EARN
INVESTMENTS.TH
BUT YOU THISGNOUT IDENT KNOWING
GOING ON, THE PRESIDENING
TA
EXTENT, AND ALSO GIVING
THAT'S WHAT PRESIDT BIDEN DID.
AN FOREVER GRATEFUL THAT
WE HAV.
AND A PIECE OF
TH G REALLY, IG THE WHOLE
>>U HEAPE OF AMERICA
COUPLE OF YEARS, FACED A LOT
OF CRITICISM, PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE, FROM YOUR FW
DEMOAT
HAVE GUTS TO UP TO SPECIALID
INTEREST.
MA YR WORDYAPAL SAID WEREN'T A
HOW DOES IT FEEL DEMOCRATS ARE
ARING TO EMBRACE THIS
LEGISLATION?
PERSONALLY AT ALL.NE OF THAT
FRUTIEY HAD AND EVERYTHING.
I DON'T LOOKT IT AS POLITICS.
I DON'T LOT DECR
BECAUSE I HAVE A D BY MY NE
AND I DON'OKT MY AN COLLEAGUES
ENEMIES.
OSAR
WE'RE ALL AMERICANS.T WE PUTUR T
THAT'ST .
I'M NO M